wir kommen zur heutigen sitzung und es
sind sehr viele von ihnen da und das
lässt darauf schließen dass sie jetzt
können wir nichts über kausalität hören
wollen sondern über die hausarbeiten wie
man sie schreibt und das mache ich jetzt
auch und zwar sage ich jetzt etwas
formales zu dem haus arbeiten hier
schreiben wir nur hausarbeiten also in
anderen seminaren können sie auch sms
schreiben bei mir irgendwie hausarbeiten
wie können sie gerne mit mir sprechen
also wenn sie jetzt gerne ein bestimmtes
thema behandeln würden empfiehlt es sich
das mit mir zu besprechen
weil die themenfindung ist manchmal
recht kompliziert und nicht jedes thema
was auf den ersten blick so interessant
klingt ist dann auch wie der hausarbeit
zu bewältigen
das ist das problem und generell kann
ich schon mal sagen von vergleichen
würde ich eher abraten
also lassen sie sich nicht so viele
würden auf sondern konzentrieren sie
sich eher auf ein spezialist thema also
weniger ist mehr weil sie dann in dem
weniger text viel mehr interessante
ergebnisse erzielen könnte durch
scharfsinnigen analysen und
problematisierung ich werde aber auch
ein paar mögliche themen ihnen
zugänglich machen als ein paar
hausarbeit themen vorschlagen wenn ich
die vorschlage werden es aber immer
oberthemen sein und dann müssten sie
dann eben noch ein bisschen genauer dann
das thema formulieren also natürlich
kann man sich sagen zb macassa -
bedingungen die wir heute noch einmal
behandelt werden ist sie überzeugt
das wäre zum beispiel eine eine eine
mögliche themen stellung und da könnten
sie sich dann noch in dieser arbeiten
auch die frage stellen welche und
theologie hat denn bitte schön
kausalität
was sind denn jetzt bitteschön ursachen
läuft es bei mac i nicht dann auch
wieder auf seine situation heraus dass
hinaus zu wachsen
das werde ich ihnen auch zu schicken
40.000 zeichen bei bachelor aber bei
hausarbeiten sind es nur 25.000 zeichen
also ich sag mal so gut
15-16 zeit ungefähr ja das wäre
vielleicht gut für ist vielleicht ein
bisschen mehr also teilen sie mal so
40.000 zeichen inklusive leerzeichen
abgabetermin ist der 25 märz 2009 10 um
23 uhr 59
und das können sie dadurch realisieren
dass sie mir ihre hausarbeit als
pdf-datei schicken und dann können sie
mir das eben noch pünktlich absenken
wenn sie im spam ordner landet haben sie
pech gehabt
also geben sie einfach hier noch als
betreff nicht zeit seminar sondern das
ist jetzt der falsche titel hier
kausalitäten hausarbeit qualität seminar
ein
und ich sehe dem spam ordner waren die
eingegangen ist und wenn die eben
normalerweise landen die nicht im spam
ordner ich werde ihn auch zu jeder e
mail die sie mir schick mit ihrer
hausarbeit noch eine kurze bestätigung
geben empfangsbestätigung also falls sie
keine empfangsbestätigung bekommen
fragen sie ich habe ihn doch die arbeit
geschickt wie sieht's aus
ich versuche das zeitnah ihm zu geben
also wenn sie es mir
ich werde in dieser nacht lange
aufbleiben am 25 märz bis 1 uhr auf
bleiben bis kurz nach also am 26
da musste ich einfach ein bisschen
aufbereitet es habe kein problem ich
gebe ich versuche in derselben nacht
noch die rückmeldung zu geben damit sie
beruhigt schlafen kann per e mail
ich habe das ja auch noch als merkblatt
ungeschickt dann die die leibliche sache
mit der krankheit falls sie schwerer
krank sein sollten werden sollten dass
ich nicht aufwändig in welche müssten
sie eben ein attest vorlegen nicht mir
sondern dem herrn würde ich oder
irgendjemand anderen jedenfalls nicht
mehr
da kann ich eben gar nichts machen das
ist sehr das sind die recht streng wenn
jetzt irgendwas ganz gut vorhersehbares
eintreten sollte in ihrem leben was sie
doch noch abhalten sollte und was sie
irgendwie auch nicht zu verantworten
haben
dann schreiben sie mir noch mal eine e
mail dann können wir darüber noch mal
reden über ein paar tage aber eben der
regel ist es so wenn sie eben schwer
krank sind müssen sie ein test vorlegen
und bei anderen dingen die unpässlich
sind können wir vielleicht noch mal
reden aber das geht dann eben um einige
wenige tage die sie dann noch bekommen
könnten dann die übliche sache da will
ich jetzt auch nicht so weiter eingehen
schriftgröße 12 times new roman 1 1,5
facher zeitabstand haben sie eigentlich
allem eine instruktion video mein
screencast gesehen auf die lowcost haben
sie das gesehen ich habe ein screencast
gemacht als dass ein screencast ist ich
habe mal eine musterhaus arbeit für sie
formatiert an meinem bildschirm und habe
das aufgezeichnet wenn ich ein neues
bewegung welche klicks dazu nötig waren
gehen sie mal auf di luca ist eines der
neuesten videos wird ihnen aber das
wissen sie es schon weil sie jetzt hier
im master studiums sind aber da zeige
ich also wirklich wie man den mauszeiger
hier also bewegt und wo man dann auch
formatvorlage klickt usw
schauen sie mal zehn minuten eine
instruktion deswegen überspringe ich das
jetzt das können sie sich falls sie es
nicht schon wissen im internet bei mir
anschauen oder auch auf anderen
ich möchte eben da sie das
inhaltsverzeichnis automatisch
generieren lassen mit der option
formatvorlage und das werde sie das
nicht wissen wie das geht schauen sie im
internet bei mir würde das problem ist
dass eben viele oder ich auch am anfang
das inhaltsverzeichnis daneben müssen
sie mit solchen punkten dann füll
punkten also leertaste oder wie auch
immer generieren und dann verschiebt das
ganze
das sollte man dann gibt es die
seitenzahl stimmt nicht mehr das kann
alles alles automatisch einen abgenommen
werden dann als pdf natürlich schicken
damit eben das dokument eben nicht mehr
sich verändert im verlauf des access des
lcs leben sie es gründlich durch und ich
muss eben immer wieder auf konter und
konjunktionen hinweisen das ist die
folge der rechten fahren nicht mehr so
präsent seltsamerweise commerce und
unterordner konjunktionen wie weil das
obwohl darin dem sind ganz wichtig also
versuchen sie immer wenn sie so ein
konjunktion die er sehr wichtig ist weil
sich hier begründen
also eigentlich die philosophische
arbeit zeigt sich an der verwendung
solcher wörter weil das obwohl da das
sind die signalwerte dass sie
argumentieren
also wenn sie verwenden sie viele dieser
wörter und verwenden sie sie nach einem
komma und zeigen sie dadurch dass sie
ihre gedanken gliedern also darauf muss
ich eben noch hinweisen die kommata ist
kommata werden in der regel zu selten
verwendet gliedern sie ihre gedanken
auch durch die verwendung von kommentar
von konjunktion titelblatt unser haupt
titel untertitel deshalb ich alles ganz
ausführlich in einem demo-video ihn
schon gezeigt online können sich
anschauen also titel ist mir ganz
wichtig über titel untertitel
pointierter titel denken sie daran der
leser will auch das interesse der
leserinnen
dieses will schon mit dem ersten satz
der erste titel satz oder titel begriff
geweckt werden
also sollten schon sich darüber falls
nicht schon gemacht habe ich glaube das
können sie schon alle
aber so eine titelwahl ist durchaus
reizvoll
es macht auch spaß einen guten titel zu
finden und ihn gefunden zu haben
aber verwenden sie darauf einige mühe
dass der titel aussagekräftig ist
obertitel kann ein bisschen pointierter
sein untertitel dann ein bisschen
expliziter das habe ich aber alles im
video erklärt dass hier auch mit der
gliederung literatur war nachweise das
ist mir noch mal wichtig dass sie eben
ganz zentral auch für mich immer noch
ein großes thema wenn meine eigene
arbeit das ist nicht selbstverständlich
ist dass sie eine leitfrage ein leid
problem identifizieren festlegen ein
problem mein problem eine leitfrage was
ist das problem diesen text zu lesen den
text sie hatten unter einer bestimmten
leitfrage was ist das problem worum geht
es hier
und wie will ich dieses problem
folgenden lösen
dann geben sie noch kurz ihre methode an
vielleicht also um diese frage zu
beantworten möchte erst das machen wir
das machen und wenn ich das machen das
und diese atmen
das ist mir ganz wichtig und daneben
auch im haupttext argumentieren
stichwort signalwörter weil das so
weiter und im idealfall haben sie dann
an gedanken
dank der sich durch den hauptteil
hindurch zieht also hauptteil haben sie
dann irgendwie also 2
1 also hier ist 22 punkte 2.233 ist dann
schluss und der gedanken und der gedanke
wird hier schon mal so ganz kurz
angedacht und er wird dann ihr sich wird
dann hier weiterentwickelt und hier wird
dann woanders zusammengefasst im schluss
ja ist der rote faden der sich hier so
durchzieht
also argumentieren sie das seien sie
logisch konsequent eines folgt aus dem
anderen um das volk ebenso wie sie am
anfang die frage stellen also wie sie
den text perspektiven man die texte zum
beispiel der von mackie der ist schon
ziemlich fokussiert der können sie gar
nicht mehr so viele fokussierung
vornehmen aber selbst ein solcher text
kann doch weiter hinterfragt werden
problematisiert werden wo heute auch tun
der heutige sitzung noch genau
schlusszeit usw
diese gliederung es eben hier die machen
sie eben mit den formatvorlagen so dass
sie dann eben diese logische einrücken
braucht dann am ende haben intracor
verzeichnis primär literatur
sekundärliteratur immer die frage ist
jetzt der text von mackie ein primär
text gut ein sekundärer text ich würde
sagen ein primär text weil er sich eben
auf keinen anderen text groß bezieht und
eben das mittlerweile ein klassischer
text ist primär tags sind klassische
text eigentlich die die wir zum zu
grundlage dieses seminars machen haben
sie alle meint rob dropbox link bekommen
mit diesen zwei ordnen ja und da werde
ich immer mal wieder was rein stellen
also da können sie sich bedienen an
diesen texten zu zitieren sie eben
am ende dann nachname vorname sie können
natürlich auch zitieren indem sie im
haupttext schon danach diesem wort nach
dem satz nach dem zitat eben dann hier
dann hat die frau müller 2000 8,3 zb so
zitieren das können sie auch im
haupttext macht und dann kommt der
nachweis oder sie können das so machen
dass sie hier
da unten ist mir eigentlich egal
machen sie es einfach nur einheitlich
das wäre mir wichtig genau das haben wir
genau das ist noch so ein punkt auch da
mache ich mein eigenes video dazu das
kommt mir jetzt zum problem des plagiats
dann mache ich eine eigene team sendung
dazu das kommt mir jetzt weil das ist
nicht ganz ganz interessante sache
die philosophie des plagiats also ein
plagiat ist ja nichts wenn sie bei
meinem vortrag letzte woche war ich habe
einige warnt von ihnen dann wissen sie
warum es mitglied will jetzt darum dass
ein irrtum nicht ein versehen ist sind
wird schon mal sind zu rechnen
und genauso ist es mit dem plagiat das
plagiat ist nicht nur ein irrtum es ist
auch ein irrtum
das sind der sehr im seltensten fall
bewusst sein es ist eine form der selbst
lüge
also wir belügen uns im plagiieren
selbst ganz komplizierte psychologische
angelegenheit also sie kennen alle den
größten plagiator bayerns brauche ich
jetzt nicht nennen
und der hat das nicht absichtlich
gemacht ist meine behauptung also der
hat das nicht er hat sich nicht eines
schönen tages gesagt so entsetzlich mich
hierhin und jetzt schreibe ich das
größte plagiat der bisherigen
wissenschaftsgeschichte in deutschland
sondern der hat sich übernommen und er
hat sich vermute ich mal auch selbst
illusionen hingegeben dass man weiß dass
er seine dissertation an verschiedenen
pcs geschrieben hat und immer
verschiedene versionen auf verschiedenen
disketten hat damals waren es noch
disketten und der kam dann durcheinander
und irgendwann wusste er nicht mehr ist
jetzt dieses dieser satz von mir oder
ist der von von einer anderen quelle
und wenn der ersatz toll klingt der
gedanke toll ist dann muss er ja
eigentlich von mir sein
das kennt sie alle das ist so
einleuchtend das muss mein gedanke sein
und wenn jetzt nicht mal ein gedanke ist
dann hatte ich den gedanken aber
vergessen also eigentlich wusste ich es
ja schon sie kennen diese diese
überlegung und ich glaube dass so
plagiate zustandekommen ich glaube nicht
dass da jemand jetzt hier ganz
wesentlich jetzt einfach mal hier so
tricks ich glaube man mit lügt nicht die
anderen im plagiat sondern belügt sich
selbst plagiiert
das ist also meine theorie und dazu
werde ich auch noch ein video machen das
heißt lassen sie auch seien sie selbst
kritisch zu sich selbst
haben sie den gedanken jetzt schon
gehabt oder nicht wie sind sie auf den
gedanken gekommen und es nicht schlimm
als zitieren und dann aber immer zu
sagen hier folge ich dieser person und
hier weil ich ab es ist ein punkt und
eben also dass diese agieren und mit
diesen internetquellen auch ein bisschen
vorsichtig sein ich habe da schon viel
darüber gesagt mache ich vielleicht auch
noch ein video dazu wikipedia mit den
nicht zitieren weil mach es kurz
dahinter keine autorin kein auto steht
den man zitieren kann
sie sollten immer in sivas zitieren eine
autorin ein autor anführen der oder die
dafür geradestehen muss für das was er
das sind verzapft hat im guten wie im
schlechten
und es gibt es bei wikipedia nicht gibt
es unter den wikipedia-autoren hat von
ihnen schon mal jemand bei wikipedia
mitgeschrieben nicht ich habe schon mal
gemacht und das kann jeder und was man
wenn man eine änderung einführt dann
wird die diskutiert in der kommune
da gibt es teilweise bots als zb potts
winterfutter zu unterscheiden ob jetzt
diese artikel wirklich relevant ist oder
nicht bringt etwas abgelegen ist oder
eine bestimmte person ein artikel machen
möchte dann kann das sein der pro tag
nur die person ist nicht bedeutend wird
wieder gelöscht so was gibt habe ich
schon erlebt
oder dass man eben dann ergänzung macht
und dann wird die ergänzung modifiziert
dann kommt die ergänzung nicht im
haupttext sind die ergänzung kommt in
die fußnote die anmerkung das macht die
community also dass da gibt es eben
schon erfahrenere nutzer und den
kameruner widersprechen kann wieder
zurücknehmen und dann das ist so eben
dieses demokratieprinzip also dieses
gegenseitig kontrolle
das glaubt auch meistens sehr gut es
gibt exzellente wikipedia-artikel die
besser sind als manche wissenschaftliche
artikel das gibt es tatsächlich also
eigentlich sollten sie in manchen fällen
wie peter zitieren anstelle der
regulären literatur aber das problem ist
dass sie dahinter kein auto haben der
das zu verantworten hat weil das
größtenteils alles an ihm ist deswegen
sollten sie eben nicht nach wikipedia
zitieren aber wikipedia kann in sehr
gute erste anlauf quellen anlaufstellen
geben führt die weitere beschäftigung zb
zum thema kausalität diesen qualitäts
aufsatz oder artikel bei wikipedia finde
ich nicht ganz so gut da werde ich mal
schauen ob ich im verlaufe dieses
semesters nicht noch ein paar änderungen
anbringen der ist nicht gut und der
artikel über das böse ist auch nicht gut
da habe ich dann wieder ein bisschen was
rein geschrieben und so kann man mit
schreib ich kann das auch sehr empfehlen
also ein bisschen sich mit zu beteiligen
arbeit dass sie nicht machen
und dann kennen sie das peter müller
philosophie lexikon schon mal gehört
peter müller das ist eine internet größe
ganz interessante personen hat ein
internet lexikon geschrieben aber auch
danach nicht zitieren weil es einfach zu
sehr individuell ist peter müller möchte
auch wenn ich ihnen recht verstanden hab
gar keine kein objektives lexikon wir
entwickeln das ist sehr subjektiv
gefärbt von seinen eigenen ideen
geschichtlichen hintergrund
ja haben sie noch fragen zur pause
weiter ist es ihnen klar ich werde jetzt
die nächsten noch ein paar mögliche
themen ihnen zugänglich machen
fragestellungen und werde vielleicht
auch noch ein paar sprechstunden
anbieten dass sie da auch noch mal etwas
besprechen können wenn sie das bedürfnis
haben also schreiben sie mir eben dann
eine kurze e-mail und fragen sie ist das
so in ordnung dieses thema diese
leitfrage und dann sage ich ihnen kurz
ja oder das zweit oder kein vergleich
oder achten sie doch darauf oder wie
auch immer und dann können sie loslegen
falls sie keine weiteren fragen mehr
haben möchte ich noch mal kurz auf
diesen michael john leslie mecki
eingehen auf seinem aufsatz causes and
conditions und wir haben mussten ein
bisschen schnell durchgehen und ich
möchte jetzt noch mal hier auf die leute
fragen angehen wie knüpft er an die
theorie russells an also grob gesagt
zusammengefasst es geht darum wie es mit
diesen randbedingungen aussieht also
eine ursache ist in der regel nicht
hinreichend
für ihre wirkung also ich sag mal so ein
hammer w und es ist eben häufig nicht so
dass wir machen es mal anders bleiben
gleichen beispiel wissen sie noch was er
als ursache in seinem beispiel gewählt
hatte was war die ursache um die sg in
seinem beispiel diesem haus brannte vor
kurzschlüssen
das ist als ca ich habe haben sie meine
zusammenfasst und bekommen darin hatte
ich so eine frage aufgeworfen die würde
ich gerne heute noch ein bisschen
diskutieren also wir haben hier keinen
kurzschluss und dann haben wir hier ist
der hausbank wir hatten jetzt in der
letzten sitzung ganz kurz verschiedene
mögliche probleme aufgeworfen
ein problem war die frage nach dem
hausbrand ist es diese hausbrand also
genau dieses feuer mit dem das haus
brennt oder ist es einmal nur die
tatsache dass das haus in flammen steht
das müssen wir uns aber heute ein
bisschen diskutieren was man es doch
jetzt erstmal einfach ganz weit her ist
einfach die wirkung ist das haus steht
in flammen und die feuerwehr muss
anrücken um das haus zu löschen
wir wollen jetzt also nicht irgendwie
brand mit solchen flammen oder brand mit
solchen flammen oder der brand in diesem
teil sind einfach das ding brennt
irgendwie und man zieht die flammen von
außen und die feuerwehr muss kommen
rauch qualm entwicklung usw
es ist ein fall für die feuerwehr so das
ist einfach die wirkung die wirkung ist
letztendlich die feuerwehr musste das
haus löschen
das haus löschen so und jetzt haben wir
gesagt so also k ist der kurzschluss und
der führt aber eben in der regel und es
ist die frage in der regel führt ein
kurzschluss nur dann zum house band
wenn eben bestimmte randbedingungen noch
folien und was waren das für
randbedingungen da hat jetzt also mecki
zwei verschiedene arten von
randbedingungen unterschieden her keine
sprinkleranlage genau genug eine
löschanlage und er hatte das eine sind
diese positiven sachen also dass es
brennbar ist das hat er mit einem
großbuchstaben bezeichnet und das ist
nicht das war glaube ich b
und dass es nicht diese feuer verhüten
eigenschaften hat oder bedingungen oder
umstände hat das hat er mit einem c und
einem so einem strich darüber gemacht
also dass der ausschluss von diesen
sachen als negative bedingungen dass das
nicht ist und dass das nicht ist und
dass das nicht ist ich glaube trotzdem
dass wir alles jetzt meinen die
bedingung einnehmen können wir machen
jetzt einfach seine konjunktion wird
noch formuliert es ein bisschen anders
und die bedingungen und daraus folgt
in der ausbauen
man geht sagt aber jetzt sagt aber ganz
kurz jetzt sagt aber mac i jetzt gehen
wir mal hier gerade zu diesem zu diesem
berühmten krone - ich habe das noch mal
ein bisschen aufgedröselt hier also call
call center bieten inzwischen das ist
was necessary path of conditions stc
vanessa fischer result ist nach der
hausbank das ist jetzt das wo wir noch
ein bisschen nachdenken müssen haben sie
jetzt probleme mit dieser formulierung
würden sie sagen dass also der grund
wirklich die ursache dass die wirklich
im sinne einer solchen - bedingung
angegeben werden kann
also bis jetzt ja nicht freundlich sein
sie gleich dazu
erst recht etwas anders sein dass unsere
mannschaft
muss nicht der putz lossagen das ist
nicht nur hat sie wird in der bedingung
ist dass diese bedingungen dem hausbrand
verursacht und das ist sie würden bei
diesem - des necessary kritisieren also
die dieser bedingung dieses diese
necessary das dass das hier
es ist
ja das ist jetzt die spannende frage wir
sehen wir können das hier vielfach
diskutieren jetzt hat es sich hier noch
immer gemeldet
wie lange dieser ausfällt
politik muss regelung nicht diese haus
an haus und in cortina gegenüber
infektionen gekommen
als inzwischen ist erstmal nicht
ausreichend nicht ausreichend ergebnis
aber durch als inzwischen nicht
hinreichen nicht ausreichend also karte
kabelbrand der kurzschluss der
kurzschluss müssen sagen der ist nicht
ausreichend
das ergebnis nicht auswählen nicht
ausreichend für das ergebnis aber und
jetzt kommt das zweite er ist ein
notwendiger teil einer bedingung die
also nehme ich das hier
und diese bedingungen zusammen ist eben
nicht notwendig sondern hinreichend für
das ergebnis
und wenn er sagt also nicht notwendig so
hinreichend für h
dann scheint er doch in diesem fall bei
hausbrand nicht diesen speziellen
hausbrand zum einen sind einen
allgemeinen hausbrand wenn er eben sagt
es ist nicht notwendig sondern
hinreichend für das ergebnis
und jetzt habe ich ebenso ein problem so
ein bisschen das aber in der
zusammenfassung schon mal können wir
diskutieren ist er ist es wirklich ein
notwendiger teil einer bedingung die
selbst nicht notwendig ist sprich dieses
jahr hier ist es wirklich notwendig oder
könnte man da nicht auch noch was
anderes einsetzen
ja das hatten sie sich gemeldet
lesen sei es nicht nur wenig gefahr aber
notwendig damit die kondition ausgaben
im landesbereich dafür wäre der moment
wenn wir nicht klar dass die koalition
nicht genau
die frage ist halt ist es eben ist eben
dieses k oder könnte man nicht noch was
anderes einsetzen statt k das war mein
gedanke als setzen wir l 1
alles was anderes okay dass es dann zu
was analytisches würde ihr so eine art
ja sie haben die torte ist hatten sie
sich gemeldet ja okay und daraus würde
logisch folgen dass eben km notwendig
ist
aber dann scheint er doch hier in
speziellen hausbrand sich zu denken oder
in diesem fall ist es nicht dann so dass
er dann hier eben nur wird sie nichts an
dieser
der von diesem kurs verloser der aussage
wenn ihr sagt der verließen im anschluss
war so gesagt und das ist im vergleich
dazu den ausstoß um sich anzubieten
ja ja weitere merken dazu ja
dass sich diese der bausparexperte der
die frage stellt machen welche ursachen
gesetzt welcher ausgeschlossen werden
aber die tausende sterben stellt sich
ein
das angesparte fragen wenn ich meine
wenn sie von der versicherung
es ist eine andere vorgemacht
wenn sie von dem haben habe ich glaube
dir habe ich glaube das beispiel mit der
versicherung ist sehr gut weil die
wollen ja immer wenn es ums geld geht
dann schaut man eben ganz genau hin
[Musik]
andere situation
die brennbarkeit und das schwimmen eine
stunde
was ist der spezifische thies enthalten
denn ich kann in jedem fall sagen das
haus ist abgebrannt meinem entschluss
war weil ich kann es schon mal sein
das heißt ich kann
wir gehen gegen die brennbarkeit eine
notwendige voraussetzung ist
infolgedessen ist es ja ausschließen
dass das ist ein witz
für sich allein und notwendig ist ja ja
also man kann glaube ich schon wenn man
jetzt da hatte er hier noch dieses c mit
dem strich tropfen aber noch als
kondition also bei uns das brennbare
material und dieses ziel mit diesem
strich darauf ist der ausschluss also
kein sprinkler und so diese negativen
als sachverhalte und ich glaube schon
dass man da wie sie es jetzt getan haben
den unterschied sehen kann in dir in
dieser konjunktion zwischen kw und
diesem strich antrieben
dem vater gibt er den ursachen es gibt
zum beispiel haus steht im wald geplant
haben das vorhaben zum kurzschluss
nachricht nachdem dienstag bekannt
das ist kurzsichtig die 1 es gibt keine
gerade das später mit konzerten
betracht doch nur ein eigenständiges
carport solche sachen bringt das alles
so werden also wir sehen hier kommt
jetzt dieses problem gleich wie wir mit
diesen bedingungen umgehen also was wir
alles in diese bedingung mit
hineinnehmen und was wir innerhalb
dieser bedingung wie gewichten und da
ist eben k kommt da schon eine besondere
stellung zu in dieser komplexen
bedingungen und das ist das verdienst
von russell dass er eben gezeigt hat
dass wir bei diesen bedingungen ganz
genau hinschauen müssen was jetzt
welchen faktor hat als ich verstehe mich
so als ein ding hat der russells kritik
des kausalität begriffs also der begriff
retten möchte indem er diese problematik
der bedingungen noch mal weiter
analysiert russell hatte daraus
geschlossen dass dieser problematik
dieser diese bedingung diese
vorbedingung dass wir eigentlich
kausalität gar nicht richtig einsetzen
können und mecki versucht jetzt das
weiter zu analysieren zu sagen doch wir
können dennoch sinnvoll darüber reden
jetzt hatten sie sich aber gemeldet und
dann zu
er erklärt auch nicht warum er dabei den
coaches stoppt dann bisher so gut wie
raus aus gar nicht gebaut worden wäre
geschlossen wird
nach süden der vorwiegend ja auch in
seiner betrachtung
also wo man aufhört als die frage nach
dem also die frage wann man aufhört also
wird sagen problem der willkürlichkeit
dass es willkürlich ist nicht begründet
ist jetzt haben wir zwei weitere meldung
erst hier und dann hier ja
und jeder von qualität für alle
genannten kandidaten genannt aber völlig
anders sagen es war das ist mein leben
ist keine einheimischen zwischen schon
vorgenommen als überhaupt ausgesprochen
hatten die ursachen die förderung kann
sie dieselben abstraktionen stufe
angehören sollen als wenn ich sage nein
aus steht dass das begründet durch das
natürlich dieses ausbau und hier
zwischen als er sonst so ein typ zu
sagen so ein typ piper cherokee meinen
sie nicht konkret das konkret ist
vorgesehen
die glücklichen gewinner muss unbedingt
die frage ist aber ob man das denn
tatsächlich building und wenn ich dann
lernt jule den lakers einen durch
kurzschluss großen hausbank ist
natürlich kurzschluss verursachen
aber ich würde sagen dass dieser aus
brand es ist keine eigenschaft ist in
diesem ordner durch den kurzschluss
verursachte zu sein denn man etwas an
dieser ausland ist durch einen schuss
uhren werden andere nicht durch muss uhr
dort wurden werde
ja also ich glaube sie haben zu recht
darauf hingewiesen dass wir überlegen
müssen wie sprechen wir vom house band
und wie sprechen wir vom kurzschluss
sprechen wir im sinne eines tipps oder
eines individuellen vorkommende sitzen
und wenn wir eben außer also typ
aussagen
also so richtig ausleben sind es nicht
mal zu setzen geschichtlich gesehen zum
beispiel dem morgen ist wissen ja schon
mal das ist dass das haus brennt will
ich vorher wer findet ihr mehr ausüben
kann und kann dementsprechend auch eine
nur so beweisen
das heißt die ursache ist nicht nur
wissen das ist falsch
das heißt nicht dass die vollen haus
gebunden sondern die feuer werden mehr
über die spezifischen brandt haus
gefunden kann deswegen zu einem
spezifischen keine spezifische art
ursache verbreitet das heißt das ist
auch die aufgabe der feuerwehr die jeder
mensch der den antiken sagen geht es
wohl eine brandursache
aber genau darum geht ihnen nicht bei
den ursachen finden sondern dass man von
dem wir wissen es ist das ausbrennen
mehr also man geht praktisch von hart
zurück auf diese allgemeine bedingungen
und analysiert die dann in diese
verschiedenen konjunktionen von
verschiedenen ereignissen oder was auch
immer mehr potenzielle ursachen
genau das ist das leben so weit ist
meine aus
aber das kommt noch dass bis jetzt
hatten sie sich gemeldet
die ganz andere sachen
das ist nur sache ja eigentlich genau
das beste was denn jetzt sehr gespannt
wie kam diese nämlich dass sich jennifer
ein guter punkt
sie sagen man muss unterscheiden
zwischen auslöser und ursachen und sie
verweisen darauf dass auch der region
gemacht hatte dass man bei ursachen
immer oder bei einem entscheidenden
irgendwie die raum zeitliche nähe
berücksichtigt das hat ja auch schon
david hume ganz klar gesagt also dass
man sagt diese kontinuität die ist dann
am ende entscheidend und das wäre
vielleicht sogar sohn grund gegen die
transit ivi tät der kausalität redaktion
dass man sagt wenn wirklich diese nähe
entscheidend ist zudem zu der wirkung
dann ist das was davor war was weiter
entfernt war einfach nicht mehr transit
relevant sind sollten wir dann wäre
würden sie sagen dass würden sie also
damit so ein bisschen gegen die transit
ivi tät auch argumentieren der qualitäts
weiter wird zurückgehen das war ja auch
der punkt zuvor gesagt haben können wir
hier nicht noch weiter zurück gehen dass
man sagt wir argumentieren gegen die
transit und sagen das ist dann hier so
eine kausale ausdünnung es verläuft sich
und wir können dann eigentlich gar nicht
mehr sinnvoll von kausalität sprechen
würden sie das dann zu sagen
diese laute und die gutachten
jetzt hatten wir erst noch jede meldung
und dann sie erst noch hier
das ist qualität und definiert dann aus
dem fall von dem verfahren
ausgeschlossen anschluss des konzertes
edition zu finden
ok jetzt haben wir noch einmal das
[Musik]
also lässt
passivität ist
naja ok interessante hinweise also die
die materialermüdung sozusagen die ja
selbst nicht wirkt eigentlich da findet
ja nichts wirken des staates sind nur
ein versagen letztendlich also eine
privat ions an eine causa in effizienz
könnte man sagen
oder wie wir das noch geschrieben ja
also eine einem mangel ursache causa
causa privat iva so das war ein kam ja
eine private sache eine beratungsbüro
sache also ist es sehr gut dass ich
darauf hinweisen wie auch der
kommilitone zuvor das unterscheiden
müssen zwischen ursache anlass und
auslösen zum auslöser denkt man das war
jetzt der letzte tropfen der das fass
zum überlaufen gebracht hat und dann
neigt man schon dazu eigentlich das
sagen so der tropfen war die ursache
dafür dass das fass übergelaufen ist
aber man wird dann immer sagen ja gut
aber es war jetzt eben schon ganz voll
da waren eben viele andere tropfen die
davor schon reinziehen
das war jetzt nicht dieser tropfen als
solcher es hätte auch anders sein können
da muss man wirklich darauf achten auf
diese sache und ich wollte auch noch mal
diesen zusammenhang
ich habe sie nicht übersehen noch mal
auf eine andere sache hinweise nämlich
das problem der kausalen ausdünnung wenn
wir also von ursachen sprechen im sinne
dessen was sich in der welt ereignet wie
zum beispiel sohn kabelbrand so dann
können wir immer weiter haben wir das
problem dass immer weiter zurück können
eigentlich also diese weiteren
bedingungen usw
wir können auch den kabelbrand nochmal
weiter untersuchen das auto auch so ein
punkt was passiert denn bei den
kabelbrand wenn man den weiter
analysieren
der hat ja auch noch meine arbeit als
zielstruktur wir könnte weiter
letztendlich auf molekularer ebene auf
atomarer ebene gehen wenn wir dann den
entscheidenden funken haben wollen der
das ganze dann auslöst als das der
entscheidende schalter der umgestellt
wird
und wir kommen da eigentlich bis ins
unendliche
wenn wir nicht das prinzip der transit
ivi tät aufgeben
mir scheint wenn wir nicht dann sagen
das ist eine kausale ausdünnung wir
müssen hier notwendigerweise hier den
rahmen machen weil alles andere ist
nicht mehr einheitlich proportioniert
oder portioniert und das bringt mich
jetzt zu dem gedanken dass man sagen
kann dieses problem dieser kausalen
ausdünnung dieses immer weiter
zurückreichen der ursachen bis endlich
ein bisschen detaillierteste kann man
dann vermeiden oder stellt sich da nicht
dieses problem wenn man von der ursache
ausgeht als einer akteurs ursachen
wenn man zum beispiel an sagt was der
grund war nicht ein ereignis als
ereignis kausalität dessen jetzt alles
ereignis kausalitäten die wir jetzt hier
behandeln sei es jetzt causa effizienz
sei es causa material ist wie sie meinen
wenn man sagt der grund war eine
menschliche person die gehandelt hat und
wenn wir diese diesem grund geben dann
gibt es glaube ich es sei denn wir
betrachten sie naturalistisch bringen
sie als ein freies wesen betrachten dann
gibt es eben da dieses problem der causa
ein auszug nichts scheint mir und dieses
problem das immer weiter zurück reicht
denn die krise sondern sagen wir sie war
frei und sie hat sie war eine spontane
kausalität zur sache sie war eine causa
sozusagen also sie hat letztendlich die
person die kausalketten ausgesandt aus
sich selbst heraus ohne dass diese
kausalketten weitere vorläufer
kausalitäten hatten also wenn das jetzt
alles konstanz sind dann ist hier eben
die person sozusagen der ursprung der
ganzen causa ketten und man das was
davor war interessiert uns nicht so fern
wie die person als freies wesen und
nicht als ein
die terminiertes wesen jetzt mal ganz
allgemein gesprochen anzieht gleich
manche naturwissenschaftlerinnen und
naturwissenschaften würden sagen ja gut
aber die entscheidung wiederum die
basiert auf diesen hirnorganischen
vorgängen und die wiederum hängen mit
einem ereignis zusammen war es vor 500
jahren war und sofort und das kann
natürlich dann auch sagen aber wenn man
sie eben als ein nicht in diesem
naturalistischen sitte terminiertes
wesen verstehen können wir sagen der
grund ist eben die person
natürlich braucht man dann kann man dann
wieder fangen aber warum hat sie gerade
das
und warum ich das was dann der grund
dafür
und dann sagen manche indifferenz kann
man nicht wissen wir haben so ein
liberta realismus der ist mit seinem mit
sondern mit seinem gewissen in
determinismus verbunden ist in
determiniert kann man nicht wissen ist
dann wiederum ein bisschen
unbefriedigend weil wir doch die gründe
wissen wollen für dieses handeln dieser
person sehen mal kommt ein großes
problem jetzt hatte sich aber hier
hinten jemand glaube ich gemeldet hat
sich erledigt jetzt hatten sich glaube
ich ihr sehr
in brand gestanden
löschen können und dann feurige
gehandelt hat oder sich umfassend und
stetige dieser situation muss dafür
gesorgt werden dass brenders nach
jahrelang gedeckt werden wieder einer
nicht gehalten
die versicherungsgesellschaft handelnden
personen der raubtiere im versicherungs
bedingungen gehalten haben
also man geht dann auch auf die person
wieder zurück wenn man versucht dann
immer von der ereignis qualität zu
akteuren qualität zu kommen um eben
diesen problem vielleicht auch dieses
regresses zu entgehen dass man eben
etwas dingfest machen kann
wer dann am ende zahlen muss so dass er
bei dieser brücke wird es natürlich so
sein dass am ende die ingenieure oder
die überwachungs firma denken sie an
diesem stein sturz dieser eiskunstlauf
halle in bad reichenhall das wasser
knapp vor zehn jahren das so da waren
dann glaube ich die ingenieure oder die
die überwacher wurden dann glaube ich
herangezogen weil sie das nicht nach den
damaligen bestimmungen durchgeführt
hatten bauern architekten wenn die ein
material verwenden was zum beispiel
leicht rostet zum beispiel billigen
stahl verwenden den sie nicht verwenden
dürften aufgrund der vorschriften
dann rost das ganze gerüst innerhalb des
betens man sieht es nicht weil das er
innerhalb dieser struktur ist und
irgendwann stürzt das ding halt ein bei
einer bestimmten belastung
und da könnte man jetzt sagen es war
einfach der schnee die schneelast die
irgendwie der auslöser war
oder vielleicht auch die ursache aber
letztendlich war eben dafür
verantwortlich diese person die nicht
darauf geachtet hat das leben unter
solchen bedingungen so was passieren
könnte jetzt hier
[Musik]
diese ursache dass jede die bestimmungen
da geht es auch um schalter es uns
vorstellen dass die bringen wir bieten
keine notwendigkeit eines kaputt
gegangen
der einstieg ist beide sie baufällig
sondern nur weil es in folglich darauf
ausgelegt sein sollte
das stärke zu verstehen deswegen ist es
trotzdem genauso alle vorschriften hier
ihren heutigen gebaut werden
dann kommt halt sein wahlergebnis steht
dann wird es vielleicht zum anschließen
und dann wären ja ich denke dass das
sind dann am ende praktische gründe dass
man das eben gewisse vorschriften gibt
die auf erfahrungswerten passieren dass
man sagt eben hier in deutschland baut
man so und anderswo auf der welt baut
man vielleicht nicht so stabil weil man
nicht so starken wettereinflüssen
ausgesetzt ist oder in manchen gegenden
vielleicht noch stärker war der punkt
wollen sie gleich dazu
die sich vor ort zu leiden dass wir es
scheint es würden verschiedene fragen
vermischen was einmal erzählt frage
und das ist glaube ich auch dass wir vom
endlich erscheint ich glaube seine show
sport und speed oder werden quasi sind
indischen oder bis ins netz stellt
dienst marktes lässt sich außerdem an
die strecke geht es erstmals ein drittes
kausalität und noch an andere right von
lisa entsprechen
das heißt wenn man sich um die methode
zum beispiel dieses textes kümmert da
muss man gucken dass in das anwesen
formen und dann zu sagen kann positionen
aus unserem gebrauch ist das spiel
zwischen kurve dann generell durchsagen
musste scheint zwischen den ursachen
gründen also wenn man sich auf gewisse
aspekte von einer gewissen gründen zb ja
dann könnte veränderungen in
physikalischen lingen
der grund wenden
andere berechnungen anderen
möglichkeiten das nur das für die
ursache bezeichnet anderen ganz grüne
und ich würde aus einem monat
aufgenommen gehören nicht in also wie
die beantwortung der frage was kostet
sie sprechen und vielleicht auch wie
sollten
entsprechen persönlich sehe ich keinen
grund diese ausbildung anzunehmen
zusätzlich konnten nur weil irgendwas
war okay okay als sie würden sagen das
ist ein historisches problem aus ein
bisschen also dass wir es nicht erkennen
können
ok und gut also sagen also die die
argumente gegen die transit ivi tät der
kausalität also diese dominosteine
effekt dass wir das bis zurück folgen
können ist ja eigentlich ihr sohn otto
logisches argument also kausale
ausdünnung wird er meistens doch unter
logisch behauptet und nicht im system
ich glaube ich aber sie würden sie
würden sagen man kann es nur bis hämisch
begrünen und nicht unter logisch diese
kausale aus
ja das ist das ist das problem wie wie
argumentiert man mit diesen thesen für
die kausale ausdünnung dass man eben
doch hier jetzt so einen schlussstrich
ziehen muss und sagt ab hier ist es
irgendwie dann nicht mehr kausal
irgendwie verständlich das wäre
vielleicht etwas zynische these oder
kausal relevant oder man könnte zum
beispiel sagen die kausal erkennen die
verlaufen also die werden die werte dann
zu diffus die sind so komplex oder so
diffus jetzt nicht mehr bis hämisch
gefragt wenn man von defiziten spricht
ist das jetzt nur für uns zu diffus und
ein anderes wesen findet es nicht mehr
die fuß sondern sagen dass es nicht mehr
einheitlich genug da muss man mit einer
heftigkeit jeder stellt sich die frage
woher bringen wir jetzt diese einigkeit
einheitlichkeit ist nur willkürliche
einheitlichkeit oder messen wir dann
vielleicht
die ursachen an unserer menschlichen maß
also machen wir so ein anthropozän
tourismus dazu sagen für uns menschen
ist das eben jetzt noch eine kausalität
struktur die abgrenzbar ist und für
andere vielleicht nicht mehr her
also ein guter punkt auf welcher basis
wir die kausale ausdünnung behaupten
können
dass die ursache hinreichend ist für den
dann kann es kein kanal aus zu und geben
den reichen bleibt sind viele schritte
wenn man aber das aber schon nicht als
hinreichend zu erkennen so etwas dann
kann es auch schon geben wollte
als solches politik sondern die
erkennbarkeit oder es zu brechen zu
erkennen dass das kann sich das
eigentlich ausbilden und wenn man
annimmt dass tatsächlich investieren
gibt und diese lebensbedingungen
dann kann man könnte sich eben
vorstellen dass die ursache neben
konjunktionen dann sind von
verschiedenen faktoren
dass man eben dann hier eben einer stufe
eins hat und dass die zweite wäre dann
frau und w und wenn wir da weiterkommen
kommen wir immer in größere konjunktion
sck niederrhein und dass man irgendwann
eben sagen würde diese konjunktion ist
jetzt viel zu unübersichtlich oder viel
zu jahr
man will ja immer die einheit haben hat
man mir ja immer die einheit
in der ersten stufe werden wir
wie der vfb sind also nur bei dazu sagen
das heißt kinder darauf durch die nacht
ist wenn man nicht
und dann muss man den weg sein wenn wir
etwas nicht die rechnung zu machen
von reinhard
das soll ausdrücken aber die gibt's
schon mit dem ersten punkt was man weiß
ja jetzt schon nicht wenn das richtig
oder falsch weil es wegen der konjunktur
wären sie eben hinreichend firmen und
unfair
sie sehen das genau aber eben die alten
sie werden unübersichtlicher als wir
haben wir können können eben eine
konjunktion von verschiedenen gliedern
nur noch schwer als eine ursache der
hinreichende ursache irgendwie verstehen
weil wir dann irgendwie dazu neigen die
in diesem fall manche faktoren hier eben
stärker zu gewichten vielleicht und dann
haben wir das problem so ein bisschen
dieser dieses dingfest machen
systemische system ist ist ja der punkt
jedenfalls hat eine weitere meldung sie
noch und dann sie
es gibt eine hohe mobilität also ein
super spiel gemacht das motiv des auf
acht verspätungen zb mann hinter
gestorbenen und dann in brand
ausgefahren
wer es keine
sie haben einander der der arme hinter
beschaffte durch den unfall getötet und
nutzt die kausalität
den jahren für die täter
ich denke es ist immer würden
ja sie wird sagen dass ich glaube das
ist
entscheidung also so erkenntnis und
interesse unterwegs
okay sie würden also je nach kontext je
nach kontext die mir das ganze
betrachten
konkreter ist schon geschrieben
die sprache wenn wir sie gleich dagegen
oder dafür dass verträge das gleiche
ergebnis sehr gerne nochmal ist jedem
ursache auszeichnet und was es um regeln
sind hier etwa sind der situation
entsprechend gebaut
dieser situation verhält nicht den
regeln entsprechend nicht mal das
passivhaus deswegen und aber ich glaube
dass eine wirkungsstarke natürlich ist
wichtig was gucken wir sagen
was ziert und dementsprechend wollen wir
auch die begründung
und das war nicht nur das hatte schon
heute im finale scranton gewisse dinge
die uns interessieren haben realität
gründung und dann zu sagen
man spreche von positiven zwischen ein
guter schritt und was für die dinge
also also ein guter punkt dass sie und
auch sie darauf verwiesen haben jetzt
noch mal das eben mecki das musst du
vielleicht ein bisschen mehr betont eben
keine unter logische untersuchung
eigentlich macht sanierende sprach
philosophische untersuchen die ganzen
angelsächsische philosophen also
schopenhauer ist noch ein totaler unter
lupe
obwohl sie natürlich da auch schon
methodologische punkte finden auch bei
kant aber also kannte es würde sei
ebenso ein erkenntnis theoretiker der
eben letztendlich auch noch mehr ist als
bloß erkenntnistheoretische david hume
ist ein paradigma der erkenntnis türken
wie können wir qualität erkennen und
kant ist gegenüber jung wieder auf einer
tieferen ebene also eben nicht nur
fragen wie wir erkennt wie wir können
erkennen können sondern was die
bedingung der möglichkeit von kausalität
überhaupt sind oder von erkenntnis
überhaupt sind also was wir eben weitere
bedingungen eingehen müssen um sinnvolle
von der kausalität überhaupt zu sprechen
david jugend setzt kz als etwas als
einen möglichen gegenstand voraus einen
gegenstand den es in der welt geben
könnte und kann problematisiert die rede
von kausalität als einen gegenstand so
etwas muss überhaupt erst vorausgehen
damit wir von kausalität als objektiv
sprechen können der ist schon wieder auf
eine metaebene und mackie und konsorten
und als gegenwärtig analytische
philosophen die wenden das ganz ähnlich
wie kant aber dann entsprach
philosophischen city fragen sich wie
können wir überhaupt sinnvoll über
qualität reden also in wenigen sätzen in
welchen kontexten verwenden wir den
begriff der ursache aber nicht selbst zu
trotz müssen wir dann uns fragt ja was
ist denn bitte schön dann die qualität
ist es ein ereignis ist eine situation
und so weiter
bei kantone stellen uns nicht gewarnt
wurde
die situation ist jetzt geschlossen
die funktion und dafür
gemacht hat so ein bisschen als eine
gerichtsanordnung regeln und ich
bestimmte dinge zusammen und gibt so
schöne stelle bei kann
funktion kann ein alien fans können mit
des college
kinder können
subsumieren aber wir können nicht
explizit
das funktioniert ja
[Musik]
danach kannte also guter punkt geht
jedenfalls davon aus dass wir den
begriff haben also wir also anders als
bei mac i wir haben ihnen bei kann schon
ein reiner verstandes begriff und wir
müssen dann nur noch durch bestimmende
urteilskraft stimme der urteilskraft
eben subsumieren
und das ist eben bei der bestimmenden
urteilskraft in der regel kein problem
das hatten sie noch mit ja
also wenn ihr keinen regeln oft die
politik an
es ist die regel genau dadurch weiß
nicht ich finde das nicht überzeugt
die text alles lösungen gefragt was ist
passiert aber wenn man ein
die operationen finden will sich ein
dann werde daher einen messtrupp
ausbreiten kann
konkret die kurzschluss und das
kassieren möchte dann würde ich kotzen
muss dass man die relation sein
das andere ist eine pflanze polizei
anzeige nicht durch die versionen des
wegen passivität ist aber wenn man ein
objekt also ein tor und einen typen
muss man jetzt in dieser bedingung
machen würde sie sagen ja also viel
dampf wird die verschiedenen
kontroversen beiträge wir sehen also ich
fast noch mal zusammen
man muss erstmal noch mal darauf
reflektieren wie redet man überhaupt
über kausalität der unter logisch oder
redet ihr transzendentale also von der
bedingung der möglichkeit er macht es
natürlich eher auf eine reflektierte art
und weise dann müssen wir festhalten
haben wir wirklich dieses problem der
randbedingungen wo hören wir auf wie
weit gehen wir dieses kann auch mit
hinein oder gehen wir noch im größeren
kontext hinein wird diese bedingung
nicht noch viel größer aufgebläht was
sind die gründe dafür dass wir an einem
bestimmten punkt abbrechen können dann
müssen wir uns haben uns gefragt wie
sieht es mit der kausalen ausdünnung aus
ist hier angebracht wenn es sie gibt ist
die app ist emissions sind nur
willkürlich oder hängt sie nur mit
unserer menschlichen beschränktheit ist
erkennt zusammen oder ist sie vielleicht
sogar und theologisch als ich sage mal
ganz ehrlich ich habe unter logische
intuitionen bezüglich der und der
ausdünnung aber die müsste man jetzt
noch genauer entwickeln also ich glaube
es gibt auch unter logische argumente
aber setzt er noch eine intuition
familie also darüber muss man noch
diskutieren dann kann man das natürlich
immer noch auf den menschen beziehen ich
glaube auch dass wir so noch auf seine
intuition erstmal dass wir von
kausalität auch wenn es ereignis
kausalität ist immer antrup home office
tischreden also dass wir immer ein
bisschen diese tendenz habe diese dieses
eine kausale relevante dinge zu finden
ob es dann am ende nur subjektiv ist es
eine andere frage aber wir haben glaube
ich schon in tendenz zu noch pausiert zu
fragen sprich ereignis qualität an
unsere akteurs kausalität irgendwie zu
messen das könnte man sich zumindest
einmal so ein bisschen fragen aber
jedenfalls ist es jeweils mecki hier
uns bietet die wirklich momentan immer
noch prominenteste form über ursachen zu
sprechen also das ist wirklich die
anerkannteste form immer noch also die
allermeisten bezieht sich dann da
deswegen ist es so wichtig wir kommen da
auch immer wieder darauf zurück nämlich
auch bei diesen netten herrn hierbei
donald davidson auf denen jetzt auch
noch ein bisschen eingehen wollen
donna davidson ist wie sie sehen im
selben jahr ich glaube das ist jetzt
dieses mal kein fehler
der ist im selben jahr geboren 117
wie merke das sind im selben jahr
geboren weg ist glaube ich ein
australier und neuseeländer und donald
davidson ist auch ein angel sachs aber
er ist ein amerikaner und donner
davidson ganz kurz dazu wie viele
angelsächsische analytische philosophen
hat donald davidson keine eigentlich
großen bücher geschrieben das machen er
die continental philosophen wie
schopenhauer die schreiben riesige werke
sind als doktor aber dass über die
vierfache wurzel vom grund von zu
berechnen grund das ist ja auch ein
relativ großes ding also in der donner
davidson hat eigentlich nur aufsätze
geschrieben das heißt nur die aufsätze
haben es in sich hat er ist eine der
bedeutendsten ihr aufsatz schreiber der
philosophischen zunft gewesen ist immer
noch sehr prägend seine gedanken immer
nur in so ganz relativ kurzen schriften
veröffentlicht aber die sind sehr
bedeutend
in ganz verschiedenen hinsichten er hat
viel geschrieben über philosophie des
geistes dafür ist das sehr bekannt über
rationalität theorie bekannt
rationalität hat dafür gestiegen und
haben eben auch über kausalität also
durch aber auch in praktischer hinsicht
hat dafür geschrieben
über einige moral philosophische themen
auch als er ist der sl schreiber dieser
mecki denn wir jetzt abgeschlossen haben
der hat auch noch ein buch geschrieben
mit dem deutschen also übersetzt
der zement des universums heißt es das
ist sein großes qualitäts buch zumindest
universums heißt kausalität eben das was
alles im universum zusammenhält das ist
da dieser klebstoff der alles verbindet
kausalität verbindet alles und das ist
er hatte dieses buch geschrieben aber
dollar davidson hat er wenn er bücher
geschrieben hat hat der aufsatzsammlung
geschrieben an diesem bestimmten themen
gewidmet zum beispiel hatte ein aufsatz
geschrieben über handeln gründen und hat
ein anderes buch geschrieben über
subjektiv intershop jeck tief objektiv
über ihr erkenntnistheoretische
fragestellung dass die sind recht
bekannte genau dass springer und jetzt
wollen wir einfach mal hier
hier mal schauen diesem aufsatz geht es
ihm natürlich auch darum wie wir über
das ist qualität reden und wir wollen
jetzt einfach mal schauen wir jetzt hier
auch diese problematik dieser
bedingungen die dann hinreichend sind
für eine wirkung wir über die spricht im
ausgang von mackie er sagt es geht mir
diesem aufsatz um die schlichte frage
welche logische form singuläre kausale
aussagen haben zb die überschwemmung
verursacht
die hungersnot der dolchstoß verursachte
caesar ist tot
jetzt kommt ein bekannter fall der brand
im stall verursachte dass das schwein
gegrillt wurde
ich weiß nicht wie der englische text
ist mit sonderschauen dass er als eine
übersetzung jetzt
die frage hier ist bescheidener als etwa
die frage nach der wahrheit singulärer
kausal aussagen oder die frage ob diese
aussagen mit hilfe eines kausalen
doctors zu analysieren sein bescheidener
ist deshalb weil sich schon beantwortet
ist wenn wir herausgefunden haben welche
logische kranken oder grammatikalische
rolle die wörter oder satzteile in den
beispielsätzen spielen und für diese
aufgabe können wir auf umständliche
definitionen oder aktualisierungen
verzichten also singuläre kausale
ursachen
jetzt kann man sich auch zurückfragen
wieder mit type und token mit diesen
generellen terminiert als er meint nicht
überschwemmungen verursachen hungersnöte
das meint er nicht jetzt sagt
verschwimmen meinte jetzt diese
überschwemmung diese konkrete
überschwemmung die am soundsovielten
dort an diesem ort zu dieser zeit die
über stiftung sagte diese hungersnot
hier sehen sie ist meinte er dass man
kann ja auch so von überschwemmungen
reden dass man der generelle dinge mit
meinen wenn man sagt die überschwemmung
verursacht die hoffnung wenn man das so
jetzt hat die überschwemmung verursacht
die hungersnot dann kann man auch sagen
eine überschwemmung verursacht die
hungersnot dann kann man gleich sagen
überschwemmungen verursachten
hungersnöte also wählt er wohl davon ja
ja das ist ein guter punkt genau das ein
guter punkt als er erste satz ist nicht
so ganz klar weil sie zu recht auf
diesen eigennamen von caesar verweisen
eigennamen da gibt es eben nur ein und
wie wir alle wissen bis er eben wohl
durch worden und daraus kann man
schließen dass es sich also um diesen
philosophen oder diesen politiker mit
cäsar war glaube ich kein philosoph
vielleicht so ein bisschen kam
historisch aber die waren ja auch er
eigentlich erst später
also es geht um ganz individuelle
singuläre kann sie alles sagen man müsse
man auch sagen dieser brand im
stahlhandel dieser brand verursachte das
also das ist ja ganz ähnlicher fall
jetzt wie bei mac i offensichtlich ja es
geht also um konkrete situationen
jetzt geht er hier so ein bisschen auf
die geschichte einer sagt jung zufolge
kann man eine ursache definieren als
einen gegenstand den man anderer folgt
bei allen gegenständen die dem ersten
gleichartig sind gegenstände folgen dem
zweiten gleichartig sind das ist die
regular ried theorie der kausalität
diese definition weil es ziemlich
eindeutig darauf hin dass wohl sachen
und willkommen entitäten sind die durch
singuläre ausdrücke benannt oder
beschrieben werden können und zwar sind
sie vermutlich ereignisse jetzt kommen
als interessante unter logische aussagen
die aber aus den sprachlichen aussagen
herleitet also das ist diese typische
angelsächsischen methode wenn wir über
unter logi sprechen dann erst so dass
wir uns darüber über die sprache
angenähert haben als wir kommen durch
unsere spezifische rede form redeweise
über kausalitäten zu einer annahme was
ihre und logie anlage ja also sie sind
vermutlich ereignisse denn die einen
können die an den anderen folgen
andererseits schreibt sich um ein
traktat unter der überschrift regel nach
den ursachen und auswirkungen erkannt
werden dass dort wo mehrere voneinander
verschiedene gegenstände dieselbe
wirkung hervorrufen irgendeinem moment
dass sich in gleicher weise bei ihnen
allen findet die wirkung vermittelt der
gleiche wirkungen und gleich ursachen
der gleiche wirkung gleich unterhalb
voraussetzen zu müssen wir den
verursachenden faktor stets in dem
umstandes suchen indem sie sophie wird
zu erkennen vermögen miteinander
übereinstimmen
hier scheint das moment qualität bzw der
umstand stadt konstanz eines ereignisses
die ursache zu sein und nicht das
ereignis selbst denn dieses ist nur
unter manchen aspekten das sind
andere ereignisse unter anderen aspekten
ist es verschiedene für die vermutung
bei jungs sei nicht eigene
sonderfaktoren die ereignisse näher
spezifizieren die eigentlichen ursachen
spricht auch dass bei ihm kausale
aussagen niemals notwendig war es sind
würden nämlich ereignisse als ursache
fungieren dann wäre ein ereignis denkbar
dass als die ursache von b zu
kennzeichnen wäre und angenommen ein
solches ereignis existiert wirklich dann
folgt logisch dass die ursache von b&b
verursacht hat jetzt etwas kompliziert
am ende wie würden sie das jetzt
verstehen bei dann hat davidson als er
bezieht sich jetzt hier auf der wied
jugend und es geht es um die frage was
jetzt und theologie von ursachen ist
sind es ereignisse
oder sind es faktoren die ereignisse
näher spezifizieren
er sagt er argumentiert dafür dass es
nicht ereignisse sind sind dass es
faktoren sind die das hier spezifizieren
wie kann man sich jetzt das genauer
vorstellen
haben sie die
ja ich denke man stellen sonst nicht
schlägt die nichtausübung weil ich nicht
auch wege sondern bei einem faktor in
das gericht als normal
unterschiedlichste personen leicht
nichts könnten nicht
das ist nicht dass sie tatsächlich die
eigens das ist auch ein faktor des
gerichts ist der grund das wäre eine
möglichkeit
es ist eben der grund dass da eben masse
ist die angezogen wird
da kam jetzt in diesem fall der waage
kann man wieder andere faktoren mit
anführen nämlich so was wie die
kavitation kraft die er auch wirken muss
auf dem mond würden wir nicht so viel zu
war auf die waage bekommen das wäre ja
ganz anders der geltende ganz andere
gravitations umstände haben sie noch
andere ideen
sonst sehen wir mal weiter als
jedenfalls machte jetzt hier aufmerksam
auf das problem der ontologie von
ursachen und er fragt sich wie reden wir
jetzt am sinnvollsten und theologisch
erst betonung auf reden das nicht auf
und logisch wir reden wir haben
sinnvollsten über ursachen
jetzt kommt auf einen anderen
philosophen zu sprechen den wir hier gar
nicht behandelt haben nämlich auf den
herrn john stuart mill und sagt jetzt
voll müssen nach mills meinung ist die
ursache die gesamtsumme aller positiven
und negativen bedingungen zusammen h das
hatten wir schon mal hier eigentlich ne
auf deren er eintreten hin die wirkung
unabdingbar folgt die
qualitätsdiskussion hat sich vielfach um
die frage dreht ob er recht hat er also
darauf bestand dass die wirkliche
ursache alle vorausgehenden bedingungen
mit einschließen muss die
zusammengenommen für die wirkung
hinreichend sind großen scharfsinn hat
man versucht
auf pragmatischen oder anderen weg
herauszufinden wie die auswahl eines
teils der bedingung als der ursache zu
regeln und zu rechtfertigen
damit besteht zwar generell einigkeit
darüber dass der begriff der ursache
mindestens teilweise mit hilfe von
hinreichend oder notwendige medium
charakterisiert werden kann
es scheint jedoch keineswegs klar zu
sein wie es solche charakterisierung auf
die einzelnen ursachen angewendet soll
das ist das problem bei mac i was wir
haben also man hat jetzt erscheint dass
er sich auf macs ein bisschen bezieht
dass wir das eben mit hinreichend und
notwendigen bedingungen eine kombination
zusammen
neben hinbekommen über diese infos
bedingung dass wir also hier eben mal es
ist zusammengenommen hinreichend ist es
aber hier notwendig also dass wir eben
über verschiedene modelle redeweisen
dann uns darüber einig werden also wie
es muss die wirkliche ursache alle
vorausgehende bedingung mit einschließen
um für die wirkung hinreichend zu sein
es ist immer das problem jetzt mit
diesem in diesem land cd ist das nennt
man ja in dieser logik nannte zieht ins
das vorhergehende und es ist praktisch
das konsequenz wir haben die situation
dass kausalitäten immer in so einem
übergang steht hier
das ist also dieses problem dieses
generelle problem auf das eigentlich
auch schon bertrand russell hingewiesen
hatte ich glaube wir können ein bisschen
weiter leser durch gibt es noch
anmerkungen dazu zu diesem
problembereich hier dann lesen wir mal
weiter
nehmen wir ein beispiel von mir
irgendjemand sagen wir haben meyer ist
gestorben an sagt ursache seines todes
sei gewesen dass er mit dem fuß
ausrutschte als er eine leiter hinauf
kletterte mir würde sagen damit haben
wir nicht die gesamte ursache angegeben
denn beim hinauf der dann eine leiter
aus zu rutschen ist nicht immer tödlich
jetzt geht es eben hier gerade hier und
jetzt wird weiter analysiert jetzt haben
wir hier also eigentlich jetzt k es ist
vergleichbar wie der held kurzschluss
letztendlich wir sagen der kurzschluss
war die ursache aber dann kommen wir
plötzlich darauf hoppla wir müssen noch
weiter bedingungen an geben als wir
wir begehen sagen einen kurzschluss wir
glauben der kurzschluss seien
hinreichend beginnen wir ein konstantes
über den kurzschluss und jetzt hier
genauso wir begehen ein ausrutscher über
das ausrutschen dem logischen
ausrutscher also damit haben die gesamte
ursache angeben denn dann hin auftritt
und einem leiter auszurutschen ist nicht
immer tödlich allerdings wollten wir gar
nicht wissen was im allgemeinen den tod
verursachen kann
sondern wir wollten die ursache für
maiers tod wissen als jetzt geht es hier
eben um die nicht um den typus sondern
das token also die singulären sache
jetzt geht es um dies und das ist doch
gegenüber jetzt von maximal eine gewisse
also adressiert das jetzt mal ganz
konkret also über wie ich eben reden wir
reden über diese allgemeinen und er sagt
jetzt eben wir reden immer über
singuläre singuläre fälle
weil man ja auch häufig von kausalität
sehr allgemein spricht ja also ist die
ursache von b da meint man einfach zb
etwas generell ist das generell tun ist
für das generell ursächlich und ich
glaube schon dass wir die tendenz also
es gibt so zwei tendenzen es gibt die
tendenz sehr allgemein von call center
zu sprechen ihm sind die sechs gesetze
ja dass man sagt also a typ etwas vom
typ a und typ b und dass wir dann auf
der anderen seite ganz die tendenz hat
bei qualität ganz individuell
hinzuschauen also ganz ganz detailliert
was war denn jetzt der eigentliche grund
dafür
und dann kommen wir in diese problematik
dieser dieser ganzen ausdifferenzierung
der ntc den bedingungen sind wir wollen
usa für maiers tod wissen genauso wie
verzehrs angst ist es dann überhaupt
sinnvoll zu fragen aus welchen
bedingungen maiers tod unabdingbar
erfolgt will ist der ansicht ein teil
der usa von maiers tod sei der umstand
seines gewichts
vielleicht deshalb weil der ausrutscher
ihn gar nicht verletzt hätte wenn er
leicht wie eine feder gewesen wäre dass
sie uns nicht die mühe machen diesen
umstand zu erwählen erklärte er damit
dass er zu nahe liegen zeitung eine
erwähnung wert zu sein aber mir scheint
wenn maja durch den sturz getötet wurde
und wenn meier zwei zentner gewogen hat
dann war marias sturz der sturz eines
zwei zentner schweren mannes ganz gleich
ob wir diesen und wissen und sagen oder
nicht wir müssen uns somit die frage
stellen wie meyers tatsächlicher sturz
unter der bedingung meyer habe zwei
zentner gewogen in irgendeiner weise
tödlicher sein soll als geben was
tatsächlich sturz was ist jetzt das
problem hier was macht er jetzt hier
aufmerksam
diese passage
also hinein nicht weiter
ja andere bemerkung noch dazu zu diesem
punkt hier
es geht jetzt um diese individuellen
fall
diese schwierigkeit hat mit mills
umfassender ursache speziell nichts zu
tun denn sie betrifft jeden versuch
bestimmte ursachen als mengen von
notwendig oder in welchen bedingungen
aufzufassen
so stellen und jetzt kommt eben dieser
bezug zum happy so stellt zum beispiel
mecki die frage was das sachverständigen
urteil dieser kurzschluss verursachte
den brand genau bedeutet
und er beantwortet die frage es ist klar
dass die sachverständigen nicht sagen
dieser kurzschluss zwar eine notwendige
bedingung dafür gewesen dass dieses haus
zu diesem zeitpunkt voll viel sie wissen
ganz genau dass ein kurzschluss an einer
anderen stelle oder ein umgestürzter
brennender ölofen sofern diese fälle
eingetreten werden das haus auch hätten
in brand setzen können
angenommen die sachverständigen haben
tatsächlich das wissen das man ihnen so
spricht welche bedeutung hat das für die
frage ob der kurzschluss eine notwendige
bedingung für diesen brand war in einem
kurzschluss anderswo hätten nicht diesen
brand verursachen können genauso wenig
wie ein umgestürzter brender anrufen
was nehmen sie jetzt noch aus diesem
zitat mit
das haben wir auch schon werden dass es
immer genau also es geht immer um die
frage nach der konkreten dieser ursache
aber auch um die konkretion bewirken
die beiden müssen immer auch
mitbestimmen wenn man bestimmte
ereignisse als bedingung bezeichnet
stiftet man damit nur verwirrungen
vielleicht sind jedoch ursachen gar
keine ereignisse und das ist jetzt diese
these die am anfang auch schon den
ausgang von david hume so ein bisschen
vermutet hat er sagt der faktoren
vielleicht sind jedoch ursachen gar
keine ereignisse
der kurzschluss oder meier's sturz von
der leiter sondern entsprechend wir
setzen wie die tatsache dass dieser
kurzschluss auftrat oder die tatsache
dass meyer von der leiter fiel setzte
können wahrheit' bedingungen für andere
sätze ausdrücken daher das wort
bedingungslos oder konditionen
also was möchte er jetzt machen was ist
jetzt in seinen vorschlag jetzt noch am
ende die zinssitzung
ich möchte ganz offensichtlich und eine
anthologie der ereignisse beginns einer
unter logi der tatsachen
als er möchte das ganze sprachlich
fundiert wissen
das war ja auch ganz am anfang der
sprache lokalisiert und das war auch
ganz am anfang unserer frage die wir
gestellt hat was sind jetzt für
onkologische fälle möglich wenn wir nach
ursachen fragen hat mir diese prozesse
ereignisse situationen und aber eben
auch tatsachen das war auch so ein
kandidat
und da ist jetzt offensichtlich donald
davidson einer der großen befürworter
dieser frage nach der unterlagen der
tatsachen
und zwar wird der clou der sein wir
müssen jetzt leider auf wenn aber der
punkt ist offensichtlich dass er sagt
sätze können wahrheit' bedingungen für
andere sätze ausdrücken
alles hängt wohl mit den wahrheitsbeweis
er möchte die rede von kausalität von
dieser die ontologie oder ereignisse und
theologie weg bringen in seiner
tatsachen anthologie hin zu einer
gewissen logischen form
oder was meinen sie
das müssen wir in der nächsten sitzung
genau noch wir haben das ist jedenfalls
erst mal nur der zugang wir werden in
der nächsten sitzung diese frage weiter
aufklären müssen
dahinter steht natürlich so ein bisschen
der verdacht dass davidson weil er eben
ein sprachphilosoph ist eben die sprache
so wichtig machen möchte und eben
wegkommen möchte von dieser problematik
der ding anthologie ereignis und
theologie hin zu romantischen
verhältnissen was es ihm offensichtlich
leichter macht über sie zu reden
die frage ist ob wir damit wirklich ein
vorteil erreichen oder ob wir damit
nicht eigentlich nur unsere redeweise
beschreiben wie wir bei konzerten und
ich die kausalität wirklich die frage
ist also kommen überhaupt aus unserer
sprache heraus wenn wir qualität
betrachten ich glaube wir müssen aus der
sprache heraus kommen können da wird sie
sagt nein bekommen nicht aus der sprache
haus deswegen müssen wir die sprachliche
form der kausalität als gegenstand der
betrachtung setzt